right here we go
[Music]
i'm having a mayor you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
i'm peter crouch this is declan we're
gonna take a penalty shoot out like no
[Music]
other
a teddy bear
how do you take a pen with a teddy bear
[ __ ]
what is going on i don't want to kick
him in the face i feel bad
i'm just kicking from beyond ah the poor
little bear it's outrageous
oh
[Music]
dreamlike
[Music]
i'll take that i could go anywhere pete
what you liking gold son well you'll see
i'm
awesome
[Applause]
oh you've got this i'm having a man no
pressure then
you ready i know where this one goes
oh
[Applause]
take the tennis ball all right
[Applause]
it's a terrible pen as well awful keeper
oh my god i went through my hand
didn't even need to die you could have
just give me that one like i could put
your foot on it
in that fielder poor that was poor
our football oh he's joking he needed
that as well he massively needed that
the worst thing is i'm under pressure
now
really yeah yeah
oh took off to save that as well
set me up do you know what i just
thought i'd send him and i've got one
more and then when i saw him go down
if i had to lift it
you don't want me to have that one
tennis balls yeah difficult one
oh no i've done that
chocolate
[Music]
not very good is he tennis ball
need this it's hard to get that up mate
i don't know if it's a topo cora no i
don't you're better than that
not a token it's not no i know where
it's going
oh oh that got over it no
is that going in no i ran over
that win that's good oh that's going to
wind me up all day long
congratulations stickling deserved that
i'm pleased you really am
great
i'll wait there
you didn't score no you do sleep over
that